the weekend
single of the year album of the year
artist of the year after being snubbed
by the grammy awards for his
record-breaking chart-topping album the
weeknd sweeps the show with five juno
wins
and if you felt a sense of deja vu last
night well the weeknd took home these
five
exact same wins back in 2016 for his
second album
beauty behind the madness and with these
new trophies he's up to a career total
of 15
junos placing him sixth on the all-time
winners list
behind the tragically hip the montreal
symphony orchestra
celine dion brian adams and anne murray
also making waves justin bieber who
opened the show with his first juno
performance in 11 years
belting his song somebody
the biebs walked away with pop album of
the year for his fifth studio album
changes but it was his friend shawn
mendes who scored the coveted juno fan
choice for the third time in his career
bringing his juneau count to an
impressive 11 wards
and after an emotional performance with
girlfriend and collaborator julia
michaels
toronto native jp sax took home the
breakthrough artist of the year award
so how are you going to celebrate i'm
drinking champagne yay
champagne hits quickly you're lucky
you're the first interview
and the strength is what makes me cry
and after countless delays due to the
ongoing health crisis
jan arden has finally been inducted into
the canadian music hall of fame
with her dear friend anne murray helping
do the honors
not only is she funny and a fine
singer-songwriter
she's also a fine human being how
special was it that your friend anne
marie
was able to present the sport to you it
was fantastic it's the only person that
i wanted so
she paved the way for so many people and
she's just a really
excellent person an excellent human
being
and fellow legends the tragically hip
received the 2021 humanitarian award
taken to the stage for the first time
since the death of gore downey
with a tribute alongside his dear friend
feist
his actions now speak for themselves so
may gord always
and forever be in your heart and inspire
us all
to take care of this world and each
other